it seems we may be entering a new phase
in the movement for
change after the death of george floyd
at the hands of police in minneapolis
across the country multiple confederate
statutes were damaged or torn down
while nascar announced a ban on
confederate flags
and as protests continue nationwide
we're also seeing some progress on
capitol hill
it was there in front of congress that
filonus floyd
described the agony he felt watching the
video
of his brother pinned under a police
officer's knee
he called on lawmakers to stop the pain
of police brutality
against black americans floyd says he
wants to make sure his brother
did not die in vain nancy cordes is on
capitol hill
nancy the house has a bill and the
senate hopes to have one tomorrow
but so far the white house has yet to
signal support for any particular
measures
so how likely is congress to get
something passed
well anthony the two sides actually do
support some
of the same things like increasing the
use of body cameras and
ending no knock warrants and that's
really the reason that george floyd's
brother
came here to washington to urge them to
go beyond the talk
and take action i needed justice for him
so i came to washington philonous floyd
marched with protesters along black
lives matter plaza
the leads up to the white house was
renamed
after his brother's death he pleaded for
his life
he said he couldn't breathe nobody cared
nobody one day after burying his brother
floyd
begged lawmakers to prevent future
police brutality
when you watch your big brother who you
looked up to for your whole life die
die begging for his mom
i'm here to ask you to make it stop
the hearing was meant to build support
for the justice in policing act
a new democratic bill that seeks to root
out
racial bias in law enforcement i feel
the pain
experienced by too many families every
single day
republicans expressed support for some
of the bill's main provisions
like a ban on police chokeholds and a
national tracking system for police
misconduct
but they stopped short of calling it a
systemic
problem the sooner we get the bad cops
off the force the sooner there will no
longer be
any bad apples to spoil the whole barrel
senate republican tim scott plans to
introduce his own reform bill
as soon as tomorrow it would increase
funding for body-worn cameras
and require police departments to report
uses of force
that cause death or serious injury let's
see if we can actually get a result
and make our our streets safer for our
law enforcement officers
and the communities that they serve
it is rare these days to see both sides
engaged on the
same issue with the same goals
especially on a topic that has
divided them in the past but it has been
difficult tony for lawmakers to ignore
these protests that have taken place in
every state plus
the polls that show that americans
overwhelmingly
support reform yeah this is a moment in
congress we'll need to recognize it in
some form nancy thank you